today we are interviewing filmmaker Kai
creative about how they managed to
successfully crowdfund their next film
which is called Rocket girl Mission to
Mars so yeah stick around we'll be
talking about how to set up a
crowdfunding page um how to come about
figuring out what budget you might need
for your project and also some film
making tips if you are interested in
that welcome Kai appearing out of
nowhere
hello hello hello can you hear me can
you see me I can hear you I can can see
you how are you doing inviting me I am
very well how are you yeah good thank
you it's 2024 starting well for you so
far so good good good glad to hear it
let's get into the interview and uh
could you please introduce
yourself yes hello every everyone my
name is Kai I um I'm I'm officially a
videographer so I'm a videographer I do
animation and after effects but my
passion kind of came from making films
as a kid and that's kind of the
direction that I'm kind of re-rooting
back into so in the early days it was
difficult to make a living from film
making as as that was my experience and
and I branched off into like wedding
film making and then corporate film
making and then now content creation and
I'm kind of like
getting back to that passion stage sure
yags you know all about that getting
distracted by the corporate world to
earn a living and then coming back money
is needed it's needed yeah exactly the
rent is always due yeah well that sounds
good I'm glad you're finding your way
back to what you love uh and how long
have you been making films yeah so I
started I actually started learning
After Effects probably about 15 years
ago as a like a a passion things I was
working as like an engineer and I
started learning After Effects I always
had a fascination with films and I was
doing that as a as a hobby probably
about 15 years ago um and then I started
properly doing video production stuff
about 10 years
ago um and yeah so I've made lots of
shorts um from those early YouTube days
if people remember those days where
people just messed around and wasn't
really serious so um and how did you
develop the skills needed to create
films when you started all those years
ago
yeah I mean if if you have a passion for
something then you're going to make it
happen so for me it was like endless
evenings coming home from work and then
learning after effects on a really slow
potato of a computer U and it crashing
every five minutes and then learning how
to do things like clones and fireballs
and it started like doing you know
started doing things like that and then
I moved on to um trying to tell more of
a story as opposed to just effects and
then I started oh I need something to
edit with now so I started using
Premiere and then the whole Creative
Suite and now moving into things like
unreal thanks to being inspired by
people like you um so yeah doing Unreal
Engine and so yeah a lot of the stuff of
this film has Unreal Engine uh used in
it and it's been a very enjoyable
paintful learning curve but I think for
for any creative it's about using the
tools that are available to you to to
create something and tell a story
whether that be art effects premere um
or Unreal Engine yeah totally agree
we'll move on to your film in a little
bit but I just remembered how we
actually first met was you were filming
in ComicCon right so yes was that kind
of your initial journey into learning
after effects did you use that to
inspire you to push yourself in that way
do you want to talk a bit about that
yeah yeah yeah um so for those so this
is what happened so basically when I was
I'd I'd lived abroad for a year come
back and I was trying to I I got into
wedding film making and I wanted to get
more into corporate film making but I
wanted to do fun stuff so I started to
do like modern pop culture events like
Comic Con MCM siy Hy Japan um I think we
did egx as well and I realized oh this
is really cool this is really fun so we
started doing interviews and and
basically it was my wife Lauren who's
also in this short film by the way um
she was my interviewer so she would go
and interview people and we'd make these
cool little like Snippets for YouTube
and then you know she she ended up
getting pregnant I don't know how that
happens I'm trying to figure it out um
and then I was like crap we've just
started making all of these um we
started making all of these cool like
ComiCon hyper Japan videos and now I
don't have anyone to present because
Lauren was doing all my presenting so I
was like I need to find somebody so all
I did was went I I went on to YouTube
and I wrote in um London vlogger I
wanted to find someone who had energy
and was a vlogger and I stumbled across
this girl called yagman X who had done a
London Vlog who was dancing in the
streets oh god of London to Oto octo Dad
it was like an octo dad
thing and I was like wow this person has
a lot of confidence to be able to do
that they will have a they will surely
be able to interview people um so yeah I
reached out to you I said hey um do you
want to do something interviews like
ComiCon and you were like yeah I'll do
that cool and then that that's how we
officially met so that was Comic Con
yeah like
2015 something like that um and then
yeah and then from there we just started
doing creative stuff and then you came
to work at Qs for a bit Yeah and during
that summer and it was like yeah we've
just done loads of little creative bits
here and there that's kind of how it's
it's crazy isn't it so if you ever want
to just do anything make videos about
anything do it I never thought that me
making a video about me having socks on
my hands dancing around London would get
me a new friend and a new job in the
future as well which is crazy um but
yeah during that time when you did all
those videos at ComiCon I thought it was
really cool and I was quite inspired at
the time as well because i' never used
after effects before and you so Kai
would create these short videos I think
it was for your YouTube channel wasn't
it um or at least you used to upload
them and it was of people in their
cosplay but Kai would use after effects
to really bring their cosplay to life so
they would become that character is that
something how did you come up with that
idea why did you want to do
that yeah I this this is this is I don't
know how how many of your audience
remember like 10 12 years ago the the
the YouTube generation of like Freddy
Wong corridor digital um a few others
that were making these special effect
videos and I was like man I want to be
able to to make cool effects and that's
what I got into in After Effects so I
thought I could I did a whole I did a
whole reel of people as their characters
using superpowers and this was before
you could kind of easily do in cap cut
so it would be like hours painstakingly
rotoscoping or masking and and putting
these effects in um and yeah even today
they don't not too bad they they've some
of them have done well some of those
little effects videos have done well um
and I guess yeah it's that's kind of
where I'm almost like heading back to
now I've gone full circle I've done like
video production for corporate I've done
like um a lot of event stuff and now I'm
like actually you know what my
Grassroots was I want to tell many
stories but make it visually appealing
and it's kind of kind of like where I'm
kind of heading back now perfect and
that's also I imagine why you like
making sci-fi films so much because you
get to play around with a lot of really
call effects absolutely yes 100% 100%
And and really excited about the stuff
that you can do on unreal now it's it's
unreal sorry for the pun uh yeah shaking
her head um yeah so it is um it is yeah
it's exciting to see like where
technolog is going I'm a dad I am a dad
I I have two kids there is proof I I I
am allowed to take Liberty with some of
these dad jokes uh yeah and um I think
involving the whole family as well just
doing something with your family that
you love and sharing that passion and
and also like my daughter Nia who is
Rocket girl basically she's just totally
up for you know being in in the movie
and role she loves it don't mean see too
many kids that wouldn't really enjoy
that to be honest um but yeah she she
does she does well she just gets stuck
in doesn't she yeah she's great I do
actually have a little clip from your
film here as well so um in your own
words uh describe what your film rocket
girl Mission to Mars is
about so rocket girl Mission to Mars oh
the trailer play I can see it amazing um
so Bas basically it's it's the followup
of of a film that we made in lockdown
called Rocket G so this is Now Rocket g
2 mission to Mars where she continues
her journey into outter space and and
really you're following it in the
imagination of of a young child who is
going through different challenges in
the first film she had a challenge of
her mom and dad kind of arguing all the
time and she like her imagination and
the way she was kind of brought the
family back together and and this uh
this film now she has a bigger worser
Challenge and that is that she has a
small brother uh that she has to share
the Limelight with so things don't go
too well until uh well you'll see in the
movie um um I love it I love it I think
it's going to be very relatable to a lot
of kids out there as well and just
looking at this trailer I can't I can't
wait to watch it you've done such a good
job using Unreal Engine in this as well
cuz you this is the second film um did
you use Unreal Engine in your first film
so this is your first delve into Unreal
Engine for filming that's really fun
that's really cool yeah awesome I love
it uh so why did you create this film
um so basically this this is a an idea
that came from Lockdown so lockdown
early 2020 most of us remember literally
nothing to do um all my freelance work
disappeared where I was working at the
time at like parttime as well at Qs uh
we didn't have any work even though we
were all remote no one knew what video
content to produce so we're sitting
there nothing to do family was all at
home and I made a joke to one of my uh
one of my family on WhatsApp about how
Nia my daughter's Nia how she's driving
us mad and I wish we could just send her
to the moon and it's weird because the
idea I was like actually you know I
could probably do that as a film and
then I made a like a PDF like a jokey
PDF and they sent out to all the family
WhatsApp groups and said hey we're going
to send Nia to the moon and people were
like this is they didn't know what it
was it was just a joke and then they
were like this this is really cool you
should do this so I was like cool and
then we spent probably about two or
three months because we had so much free
time just filming and and write you know
writing the scripts filming it trying
out different effects um and just having
fun that was the kind of the first movie
um and it has evolved into a second
movie that because people kept asking is
there a sequel or you going to make
another one and I was like maybe if you
know if I could get some funding for it
because it's not cheap to I don't have
the time now cuz back at work full time
so yeah so that's kind of how it evolved
into what it is now were you surprised
that people wanted to see a second
film yeah we we submitted the first film
to a couple of film festivals um like my
mom and dad were like this is really
good you should you should submit it to
film festivals and so we did it was
featured in our like local newspaper
here
in um yeah so so we you know we were
like okay well let's try and let's try
and kickstart
uh we wanted to kickart a book based on
the film so we did a Kickstarter for the
book and it fell flat literally we we
wanted about
£3,000 and yeah we got to about half of
that funding and then yeah we didn't get
any more uh people support us so we
realized that people didn't really want
to book maybe we should focus on doing a
second film so that's why we were like
well maybe if we kickstarted a second
movie uh and yeah and we were
successfully funded on that and yeah
that's why we pushed ahead amazing well
we'll talk about that more in detail in
a bit so don't worry viewers we will
talk about that um but I've just got uh
some more questions to ask you about the
film so are these the rocket girl films
are they your first films that you've
made I know you talked about your
YouTube videos before that this is the
longest film that I've produced so the
running time of this film Al together is
about 25 minutes um which is the longest
I'd say I think the second longest
probably between 10 yeah nothing longer
than 10 minutes in the past so this is
definitely longer and and in in a world
where we we have short form content
trying to keep people's attention for
that period of time is quite challenging
particularly like a kid so we've got a
live viewing of this and Nia has invited
all of her friends um like from school
uh and and family members are going to
be there so that will be the true test
of whether people are like really
connect with it or not yeah um and I
think that's going to be quite scary to
see as a as a filmmaker especially kids
kids are like brutally honest yeah which
is good but also a terrifying thing so
before you made this film and you
crowdfunded it you talked about you made
rocket girl one so this says films but
imagine this it just says film how did
you fund your previous film so the first
rocket girl how'd you get money for that
yeah so it was a shoestring budget it
was literally donations from family to
like the like sending over the props
paying for like the the cardboard rocket
that we used in the first one um and to
be honest with you it was essentially it
was um resource film making so after the
film I made a course I made a skillshare
class on resource film Mak based on
making that film like literally how to
um how to create a um a film with no
money basically and I think there were
like 2,000 students on that skillshare
class so a lot of people are actually
interested in how they can just make
stuff with what you have available yeah
it was it was more more than anything
it's time as most people probably
realized just to to sit down to edit um
well to script to get an idea to sit
down to edit then you know sorry to film
and then edit and and all the planning
around it and this film was so much more
because we had shots like on the beach
we had um a lot of uh different like loc
not locations we we filmed in in in in
the office at home but we had to like at
one stage we we blacked it all out with
like a corrugated black plastic stuff
yeah that they use in building and then
another stage we had to cover it all in
tin foil so it was like like constantly
I was working constantly and I had all
this stuff in the background um and you
can see that in my YouTube videos I do a
lot of YouTube review videos so you'll
see like tin foil in the background of
some of my review videos because of that
film your house was and is your set
basically it is yeah exactly cuz it's
free exactly so yeah cool and um so you
just mentioned well you've mentioned
YouTube a lot actually um is that what
pays uh your
bills so um fil the great thing about
YouTube right I know we're on Twitch
mainly but I think this is going on
YouTube as well yeah is that YouTube
like
the way that we we met it creates
opportunities out thin air right you
were dancing on the street with long
sleeves and I was like hey that's
someone who could do do something for me
and then you know we was able to be a
connection in the future and then work
together in um in Qs um so for me during
during the pandemic I lost all my
freelance work so for for context I
worked three days a week as head of
video for a company called Qs I then
freelanced on the weekends and Mondays
and Fridays for my business which is Kai
creative and all my freelance corporate
work disappeared within two weeks and
then probably early
20021 I went through redundancy at work
which was very painful and for about 6
months I was relying on YouTube AdSense
Amazon Affiliates um all all types of
like skillshare as an example to kind of
make ends meet um until I started
working with uh well I started working
pretty much with Naz Academy a month
after but I didn't properly get regular
work with them until about 6 months
after so it was uh yeah YouTube is
probably the the greatest thing and I
remember this youber right telling me to
to make a YouTube channel talking about
what I did like like my share my nuggets
of knowledge is what this YouTuber said
to me and I said to them why would I do
that because plenty of people are
talking about YouTube are talking about
about film making photography already
and she said to me um because no one can
explain it like you explain it and
that's why I started a YouTube like to
take YouTube more
seriously and uh that was
you so this is supposed to be about you
k you so thank you than you for telling
me to do that yeah yeah I'm glad I did
as well I'm glad you told me that I mean
honestly and now I mean especially with
the Amazon affiliate stuff um you've
cracked a lot of a lot of kind of the
code of how to sort of make a living on
YouTube much better than much better
than I did why did you decide to
crowdfund this
film yes um so as I mentioned earlier
previous to this crowdfunding we tried
to crowdfund a a book uh based on the
first film and through that experience
that paintful experience of setting it
all up doing like the page and making a
little video and and and kind of pushing
it constantly like we had a list of
people that we like literally down to
individuals that I knew that I was
targeting and saying like hey do you
want to support this book and most
people like a book not really um maybe
maybe a movie because you're a mve a
movie maker you're a
film so so I've been on Kickstarter like
I've had an account for a while I don't
know if anyone remembers
VGHS video game high school I remember
the buzz of and that was like at the
time was of the fastest funded
Kickstarter movies ever VGHS that like
the series it was like a series right
and it's some following this guy who
goes to video game high school um I'm
telling you Ys you need to check it go
watch it you love it um so after that
I've always thought of like yeah I
should I should do have a Kickstarter
for something because you can you can
see it from someone else's experience
how quickly they made like you know
money to to support their project um and
and then there's an artist called Seb
Chow that you know I think you might
know he he did a comic called catapulted
and I helped to make his Kickstarter
video and he was successfully funded so
I was watching that project in with
interest and I saw I saw him get
successfully funded so I thought maybe
we should try this as well and that's
kind of the reason why um I wanted to
try and Kickstart or use crowdfunding um
for a project and yeah just so happens
that we got it for Rocket Gil 2 mission
to Mars okay cool I don't know the
answer your was that
it it was why did you decide to
crowdfund this film and it absolutely
did I mean it sounds to me like you
honestly just wanted the challenge of
crowdfunding something to see see if you
could do it and you tried it with this
book and then you realized what am I
doing I'm a filmmaker I should do it
with a film I'll be honest with you when
when that book fell through we like
myself my wife we both like were
involved in that we felt really quite
miserable that we didn't get the support
that we fought
we thought we would get um you know we
made it halfway and then it just like it
was growing at the beginning and I
remember seeing the numbers go up every
day it was brilliant and then it was
almost like the stock market just went
in flatlines and we were like oh no one
really supports no one really cares and
we put a lot of effort into try and ramp
up support like we were contacting
family and friends and and and
Associates I don't know I might have
sent you a message as well saying hey Ys
check out this you might have even
supported it I don't know um uh check
out this book and like no one after yeah
after the initial burst no one cares and
that was that can be quite a painful
experience so I think I've got the
perspective of both sides like
successful and being
unsuccessful um so yeah which is good
because there there's a good few
questions here that I think you can
answer from both sides um so I'm glad
you're on today yeah okay so uh which
crowdfunding platform did you choose and
why because there are a couple of
different
ones right okay so what I would say is
if you go with Kickstarter
because I've always been on Kickstarter
since the VGHS days um It's All or
Nothing if you don't get if you don't
reach Target so you set a Target so if
you set three grand as a Target you know
$5,000 whatever if you don't reach that
you will not get the money you will not
get paid out so when you're thinking
about how much you want to get paid um
and how much it's going to cost realize
that if you get even $1 less kickstar is
not going to pay out any money to any
you they're they're not going to take
money from your backers and they won't
pay it um I think Indiegogo is different
I believe
Indiegogo you will get whatever ends up
in that pot to help you deliver your
project but then you can add tiers to
your project you can also add teers in
Kickstarter as well but it's almost like
if I me if I reach this much funding
then I can produce this if I reach this
much funding then I can expand my
project to you know extra stuff cool so
I guess yeah one of one's more forgiving
than the other but you chose kick
started just because that's the one you
had heard the most
of yeah so after doing seb's uh comic
book video and then our video we we
decided to give it another chance to be
honest if it was if I was to crowdfund
another project I might go with
Indiegogo okay or here's a thing you
could do
both both at the same time both at the
same time you can Crow fund on both as I
believe it to be presently I think
that's okay there might be a clause now
which says you can't I don't know I
don't know I don't know about that look
into
it look into it yeah I'll look into it
yeah what was the most challenging part
during your crowdfunding process I guess
because you have a failed and a
successful one you probably have a few
different um ideas right so you can set
a period of time to have your
crowdfunding on Kickstarter so we chose
I think for the book we we chose 30 days
and I think for the movie we added on a
little bit longer I think it was almost
two two months maybe 60 days um and it's
just that the anticipation like every
day when when you first kind of push it
and you you start getting those numbers
come in um it can be very exciting and
then when you Flatline and you don't get
anything for a day it can be very like
like you can feel it's weird you like
you feel like oh I'm not being supported
and and then you it does mess with you a
little bit in the psych like with your
psychology I get like the way you think
your your mentality your mental Outlook
um so for yeah for me is just be patient
and and promote it and you know if you
if you've been realistic with your
expectations and what you're offering
then yeah I think for me the just the
waiting just the hoping yeah that makes
sense because it it sounds similar to
doing anything on the internet like
YouTube as well but with YouTube there's
no end date so it's like oh it's fine if
my videos aren't doing great this month
that's cool it can always go up next
month but yeah if you've got an end date
and you know you need to reach a certain
number by that's got to be quite uh
intimidating now this one is an
interesting question um cuz I don't know
exactly what goes into creating a crowd
funding page so do you have sort of like
a shopping list of things that someone
would need to set up a successful page
so maybe like a trailer uh certain perks
like you know what would they need to
bear in
mind yes absolutely so the most
successfully backed projects on
Kickstarter have a video um if you can
physically show people what you're going
to produce
um
also yeah have a track record maybe on
social of what what you do so I can see
that yes what you're telling me you're
going to produce I can trust that you
will do it so for example if um Seb was
making his comic book and I went to his
Instagram page I would see all of his
sketches and drawings and kind of a
backlog of work of what he' done in the
past um put your socials on there so
people can see that you also want to
think about like
realistically how much you will need so
for us we
we basically sat down and we were like
how much do we need like for props how
much do we need what like kind of camera
upgrades and stuff will we need and yeah
we we had we had like a weekend away at
a beach uh you know which was going to
cost x amount so we need to factor that
in all of that stuff is stuff that you
want to sit down and think about like
what what um what do I need and and then
realistically like can I get that from
my audience right having an audience is
also really useful so a lot of a lot of
projects initially are going to be from
your family and friends like the funding
but you're also going to start thinking
about okay have I got fans that might
also support this and you know where are
they like where can I reach out to them
where can I put promotional stuff
because we did a bunch of promotional
material for Rocket girl uh both the
book and and this movie when we were
doing the kickstarter campaign and then
you want to start doing things like
thinking of the rewards you're GNA have
a reward system so where if you donate a
certain amount you will get not just you
know a behind the scenes film as well as
the main film as well as a poster a
signed poster a script um I think we go
all the way up to script and storyboard
and postcards and um digital downloads
of the like the first movie the second
movie and behind the scenes so just
having that tearer system as well is
going to make people give like more
depending on what they won as a reward
yes giving them incentives to give you
money Beyond just the final product
right that's right yeah especially for
you because are you releasing the film
on YouTube so it be publicly available
yeah so what we have this is one of the
one of the top tiers was to to watch the
live release gotcha at on on YouTube in
a zoom party like and there's a Q&A
after um and that will be one day after
the kind of live launch with um in the
hall um so yes if the bulk of the the
kickstarter or Indiegogo campaign you're
going to want to kind of list out what
the project is make it very clear what
the deliverables are so people know
exactly what they're supporting and give
dates now we did not we did not um hit
the dates that we wanted to release but
just because I didn't realize how big
this project would be and also how long
it would take to learn unre engine Jesus
Christ
it massive like I used so I started
using Miniatures I started using
Miniatures and halfway through I was
like no I'm going to use unreal for this
and then I had to learn that so that
added like six seven eight months of
learning on top of of it so but there's
a project page and you've got an update
section and you can update your
followers you say look there's a delay
because of XY Z just keep people in the
loop all the way through the project um
so they know right that you know there's
a hiccup here or something but I am
going to deliver lots of kickstarters
don't actually deliver right so they
they get the funding and then they don't
actually produce anything so don't be
one of those people that makes promises
and then takes the money and
runs okay cool next question um how do
you set an appropriate crowdfunding
Target yes yeah exactly
so so be realistic um and also realize
that you depending on how much you want
to bring the project to life you you
want to think am I do I want to make a
profit from this or do I just want to
bring this project to life right so
after talking to Seb I realized that's
quite a few of these guys on Kickstarter
what they do is they they they they
amass a load of cash from Kickstarter
they pay artists to make their their
book they make it they ship it out they
make a profit and then they go to the
next you know crowdfunding goal and
people love the comics but the guy doing
it is a business man or woman and
they've decided look I'm using this to
make a profit this is my goal for me it
was a passion thing I never wanted to
make a profit I just wanted funds to be
able to get the props upgrades upgrade
some of the equipment and a lot of the
like the the biggest thing for me has
just been time like the time suck is
massive um but having fun along the way
is part of just being a creative I think
um so you have to think about whe which
Camp you lie on are you lie in are you
the I'm going to make a profit camp or
I'm here to really bring something to
life that I love and I think when you
find out which one of those you are in
then you can decide on how much you need
for me I definitely made a loss um
because of the time that it took out of
like I like the last this last month
I've turned down loads of freelance work
just to get this project finished so
I've taken a financial hit um to get it
done on time um but a lot of people yeah
they're in it to make to make money so I
think ask yourself that question first
uh and it'll be better to help you
answer it yeah yeah good point and then
um so once you decide
did you how how did you come up with
your figure did because you mentioned
that you uh got together and figured out
like everything you'd need for the film
so the Rover and the license plates you
already had the cameras which is great
um did you decide to try and
offset the cost of all of those things
um and use that uh for your crowdfund
Target what was the decision making yeah
exactly so so for me I I already had the
the lights the the cameras the sound
equipment that that wasn't necessarily
issue it was like um the the Rover the
astronaut suits the the stuff to plaster
into the to the office um I needed
additional lighting uh for some of the
like the tube lights and stuff um uh
things about like just creating the
atmosphere I've bought a bunch of assets
from unreal as well so like storm pack
assets dust asset all this stuff that
would take me hours to build I could
just buy it from Turbo squid or from the
unreal Marketplace um and that was an
unforeseen cost because I didn't intend
to go down that route I was using
Miniatures um and actually yeah these
things came out of nowhere hotel stay um
going down to campas Sands for the
weekend to get all those beat shots
early in the morning um all of that was
factored in but like I said what I never
really factored in was my time I wasn't
getting paid for the time so all the
props and all the bits we kind of needed
covered which is fantastic um but yeah
uh my time wasn't so if you're going to
embark on a project where you want to
pay yourself then that's a completely
different ball game because then you'll
need to work out how long it's going to
take you how many days how how much your
hourly rate is or your day rate to work
on this so that you can pay your bills
and everything else so for me I was
still like working in between kind of
doing this uh project that's that's why
it was delayed for quite a while got
gotta does that make sense am I
like it does it does it does yeah what
helped get this project successfully
crowdfunded this is cool because you've
had a failed crowdfund and then a
successful one I know we've talked about
this a little bit but why do you think
this one was successful versus the other
one not being successful and perhaps do
you think having a not successful
crowdfund page helped you then be
successful on your next
attempt yeah I think if you want if you
it's it's like the laws of uh the
economy right it's like supply and
demand supply stuff that people are
demanding don't create something that
people don't want um if you're a
creative which I imagine quite a few of
your audience probably are and you're in
the like the digital domain creating
stuff then look at what people want and
try and build something around that so
for for us trying to build the create
the book there wasn't really any
interest um having a second film was
more um of interest to people in in
general uh particularly on my platform
as well as like family and friends so um
yeah and so like a lot of the initial
support was family and friends if you
look at like the the supporters it's
family and friends initially and then as
the project kind of builds and and if
you're lucky Kickstarter promotes it you
get a little promotion from Kickstarter
they show on their front page then
you'll start to see um other people get
involved and and and throw you a throw
you some um some money as well like back
it as well so that's my advice get
create something that people want I
think that that leads on very nicely to
what you said because I was going to say
how do you know what people want that's
always a massive question it's like I
want to make things but how do I know
what people even want from me and um
yeah from just already getting your
hands dirty and uh doing things online
and building an audience if you can or
at least gauging interest from whoever
is out there then you'll see um what you
a enjoy doing and then B what other
people like to see you do as well um yes
good advice good
advice uh cool cool would you recommend
someone crowd fund so if I did want to
crowdfund a horror game would you
recommend me actually do
it oh yeah absolutely um from for
someone like yourself who's an
established uh person online personality
online who has like I think I watched
one of your unreal tutorials and it was
like it blew up really quickly didn't it
the the make a music video unreal yeah
um that inspired me to use unre that
that video I was like man this is so
good um so I think yeah a lot of people
would be down for that if you were to
create something and use Indiegogo or
Kickstarter
um I don't know ask the guys here would
you guys would you guys support y's
Kickstarter campaign I'm sure they I'm
sure they would I would yeah absolutely
um what about um thank you uh what about
um someone
who isn't a YouTuber like doesn't have
that online presence already but maybe
they're like um maybe they're a game
developer in a AAA Studio or something
so they have skills but they haven't
already already started putting
themselves would you recommend them
crowdfunding a
project it it depends it depends on a
few things um I think back to seb's
catapult comic and I don't think he's
got a massive following he still has
quite a a good Instagram like page like
is really good but I don't think he's in
the necessarily in the tens of thousands
of followers but he successfully was
able to crowdfund for his comic book so
I think if you can bring and and one of
the reasons actually was that
Kickstarter promoted it on their page so
if you can get the attention of
Kickstarter with your projects you might
not necessarily needs that kind of
backing but it certainly does help to
have something to show somewhere so you
know yags wants to make an Unreal Engine
game and she's got all these tutorials
that show me how to use Unreal Engine I
trust that she can deliver on that
however if someone comes to me and I see
it on Kickstarter and you know they're
promoting it and they're like hey I want
want to make this game um but I don't
have anything to show then it's a little
bit more like well why would I trust
this person to to take my money and
actually deliver versus just taking it
and and not producing anything so I
think that trust is a big thing um and I
I know I know you I know whatever you
set out to do you're going to create it
you're going to make it so I can trust
that it will be delivered and it will be
awesome so I think that's that's kind of
the biggest thing is just building Trust
with investors essentially I guess it
goes back to the shopping list that you
were saying and one of the vital things
was the visibility on other platforms so
people can know uh what they're going to
be paying into uh yeah no that makes
that makes perfect sense
cool and
uh one what's one piece of advice just
one succinct piece of advice that you'd
give to someone thinking of crowdfunding
think about like the reason why you want
to do this project or create this thing
um
and really do like a breakdown of what
you need to achieve that like not just
not just from money but like from my
experience time um and then there were
times during this project I was just
like I just don't want to do it anymore
just bored now I'm just doing other
things like like you really want to
stick it out and produce it so sit down
and just plan everything out like on a
piece a couple of pieces of paper and
just have it VIs in front of you and
then yeah you you you you'll figure out
whether you need the funding like the
the the adage is you know if you want to
do something you'll find a way if you
really want to do something you'll find
a way and if you really don't if it's
not that big a deal you find an excuse
and then you know so you really got to
figure out the why True to this project
yeah and I know there's a lot of fear
that probably will come with
crowdfunding because it's different to
just using your own time and money
because hey if if you decide you don't
want to do it one day that's fine cuz no
one's invested in it um but I think
sometimes the more fear you feel about
something it shows that you really want
to do it um whereas if you're not maybe
maybe it's just me but if you're not
bothered then um maybe you don't want to
as much but uh yeah and I didn't think
about that actually the um you when you
say that you sometimes didn't want to
carry on with the film but then you
realize well can't because people have P
giving me money so I guess um in a way
it's uh it's a good it's a good thing to
hold you accountable to actually carry
on and get to the finish line that I
know a lot of people struggle with
that and uh the final question before we
go on to the Q&A section is would you
crowdfund again I think you've already
said this
anyway um yeah I think that so I'm gonna
like it's it's it's it's a it's a little
bit different for me now because I've
got more freedom because before I was
looking after my son most of the week
and like doing the school run and now my
son is Just Like Preschool so it's like
oh man my time has opened up so I think
the like the next few things for me are
going to be just creating more content
for my channel um I want to build a
couple more short courses uh and I I
want to do more film making like like
kind of familyfriendly stuff but more
like after effects more unreal but not
as long so I don't know necessarily know
if I need crowdfunding for those
projects but if a if enough attention
was garnered and people demanded like a
third film as an example then yeah I
would absolutely do crowdfunding but
this time I would do it like I going to
be paid for this myself so it'd have to
be like that would have to be factored
in gotcha so that would be your
learnings is that you would crowdfund
again but you'd pay more attention into
how much of your personal time it would
take up exactly sure that is the answer
yeah yeah that makes perfect sense
although I did hear that uh your
daughter wants to make the next rocket
girl film so I don't think you're
allowed to do that she's going to be
directing she can absolutely she has the
time she has the time to do
that she can set up a crowfunding page
and get all this
money he can absolutely do that yeah I
said to her if you want to write the
next script and you want to do it all
then yes you can you can hire me and I
will be your employee to to do all to do
the the
editing oh I'd love to see that one okay
so let's go on to the Q&A section so we
have I think the first one is from
Moscato and they say uh on being patient
and promoting do you have any insight in
how much of the crowdfunding was organic
growth versus people responding to your
promotion yeah so when when you when you
crowdfund obviously you get the details
of the people who have you know funded
your m movie and what I'll say is this
um majority at the beginning is going to
be family and friends there are people
that jump on it and and it starts to
push it up and if Kickstarter gets a
hold of it I I can't remember if
Kickstarter promoted it but when we
started to get a add funding from people
we didn't know and weren't subscribers
and weren't fans of of the of the
project you can look at all of that in
your control panel in Kickstarter so you
can see that so I think um I'll need to
go into it but I think probably got we
had like a 5050 split between people we
knew and people we didn't know which I
think is quite it's quite good actually
to be honest with you yeah yeah that is
pretty good we have another question
from DC
Bradshaw uh I've heard other
kickstarters say to beware of physical
stretch goals slash add-ons because of
shipping Mine Fields especially post
brexit is this something you were
consciously thinking about or nervous
about yeah this this is a good point
this is a great question um so we added
on so people in the UK it was free uh
postage or it was included to some
amount but I think if it was like abroad
depending on where you were we could add
on a a slight extra fee to cover the
shipping so we added on like3 to5 pounds
extra depending on what the tiers were
as well because if you think about it
you're sending physical stuff like
scripts we're sending like scripts and
storyboards and post cards and posters
it's a lot of stuff um and I remember
when I supported Freddy Wong's VGHS they
sent me a copy of the script a poster a
T-shirt and they they wrote the value of
it down as being like 150 bucks so we
had to pay like £50 to get it from the
post office so we got hit with the with
the tax and I was like thanks guys
thanks for hitting me yeah people
already supported them and then
yeah um so that was that that's one
thing to think about yeah um if you're
sending something physical as opposed to
digital it it's going to impact but I
guess it's it's nice to have that kind
of
extra stuff like the script and post
posters and stuff as well so we did add
them in um so yeah something to think
about guys take that into account look
at and it it really depends on what your
audience is because we've we had we had
backers from Australia and the US that I
was like we don't know these people but
like wow like these platforms are
worldwide so do really consider who
might be supporting you and how much it
might cost to get stuff to them because
that's going to eat into your
into your amount yeah I never already
thought about that cuz I guess it's it's
similar with uh with my patreon cuz I
send out cards but I don't think I've
ever had that issue I've only already
sent to us that's like the furthest away
but it's just a card so I guess it's
different depending on what you're
sending and the value of it as well um
but yeah good good Shout good
shout okay so rounding off with when
rocket Girl release and where can we
watch it it's going to release on the
21st of January which is Sunday so
hopefully you're at home um the time has
yet to be decided because I need to
arrange that with the like top tier
backers um so yeah it will be on YouTube
on the kai creative YouTube channel oh
and uh if you want a link to Kai's
YouTube channel then click on the link
in the chat now there's actually a link
to the rocket girl Bion Tamar's film
trailer uh but you'll be able to find uh
his channel through that as well so go
check it out if you're intrigued and uh
I think you should be cuz it looks
really cool and I love the fact that
you've used un real engine I'm going to
have to pick your brain about that
actually because I've recently updated
from UI 4 to ui5 and the export process
is different and it's way more bug prone
than it used to be which oh really yeah
we'll have another about that but I'm
getting a lot of like frame drops um I
even I I did an image sequence and used
FFM Peg to create the video from the
image sequence and it's just the quality
is not as good as it used to be so I
think I'm I think the problem with
unreal is that it gives you so many
options that it's very easy to make
something look crap because you need to
to utilize the options and to understand
them um to get the bo the best out of
them but the default settings they give
you just will kind of not be great um
but yeah we can chat about that uh you
used real Engine 5 didn't you for this I
have yeah I've been using real Engine 5
yes with the new updates and all of
those render setting everything I did
was in 4k and so far I think it's been
okay I haven't noticed a drop but yeah
dropping frames when I exported from 30
FPS I was still picking up as 25 in
premere so I'm not really sure why
there's a mismatch there very confusing
oh interesting yeah yeah we'll chat
about it I think it it might have been
because I was just recording like a a
sky box but I don't know why that would
have been dropping frames I was doing it
uh 24 frames not 30 frames but yeah
maybe I'll ask you to send me some
screenshots of what your render settings
were uh cuz I started watching YouTube
videos like there's so many export
settings you can do an unreal now it
used to be so simple there was just like
tick boxes and just some sliders here or
there and now there's like oh whole
sections you can tick on or off and I'm
like okay I need to relearn I'm real
engine um but yeah thank you uh for your
time uh Mustafa says it's a very cute
trailer have you watched it already
Mustafa oh that's very kind thank you
yeah that's very
kind um and direct crib says thank you
both for the streaming chat thank you
for coming I appreciate it uh and oh
there's
ah where did it go there it is uh and
before you leave just promote yourself
uh where can we all find you where do
you post the it's Kai Kai creative um
and I post on pretty much all channels
it's I'm on Instagram Tik Tok Facebook
and YouTube yeah main four cool awesome
well thank you very much it's been very
insightful uh I hope this gives people
something to think about especially
coming into the new year maybe there's a
project that you've been thinking about
you're not quite sure how to get it off
the ground without some funding maybe
crowdfunding is for
you exactly yeah exactly I think someone
in the comments did say that they
they're looking to do crowdfunding oh
they oh cool yeah I think I nice nice
yeah nice definely definitely something
to consider guys yeah this see you guys
take care
okay deck all right so there you go and
uh Kai shared some wonderful nuggets of
knowledge with us that I am very
thankful for thanks for joining us
lovely to see you here most of you are
probably back at work now aren't you so
I hope work is going well for you or
whatever um 2024 has had in store so um
I will see you on Monday have a lovely
day evening and
goodbye thank you so much to my patreons
October night games Bruce Barrett
Salvatore marfield Sherman Jackson Dave
Smith Stuart Terry I 196 and Quinn Darko
your support means so
much